for these high school students the jock
the all-star miss popular the outsider
and the pond welcome to detention boys
and girls what a cosplay Hawker it was a
Saturday club they didn't want to join
the school is being fumigated so the
district has kindly arranged for us to
stay here and what was formerly known as
wave u prison Lexi may I have your phone
[Music]
put in these hallways no open the door
once you're inside what do you want for
mine I am going to find a way out
there is no escape hello is anybody
there instead and if they're going to
survive detention this place is totally
haunted this place used to be a prison
as agreement ly insane
thanks for craving me out even more
freak show I don't have to put aside
their differences and find a way to work
together it is just trying to scare us
we can't let it get the best of us don't
make it out alive
just entertainment presents Gillian
vigman Alex franca Sara Davenport
Henry saga coy Stuart and Jennifer Robin
Jacobs some after-school activities
don't worry baby momma's got it covered
it could be top on the student body
deadly detention
[Music]
you